solve for x and check your solution we
have x divided by 3 is equal to 14. so
to solve for x to figure out what the
variable x must be equal to we really
just have to isolate it on the left hand
side of this equation it's already
sitting there we have x divided by 3 is
equal to 14. we could also write this as
3 x is equal to 14. obviously x times
one third is going to be x over 3. these
are equivalent so how can we just end up
with an x on the left hand side of
either of these equations these are
really the same thing or another way how
can we just have a 1 in front of the x a
1x which is really just saying x over
here well i'm dividing it by 3 right now
so if i were to multiply both sides of
this equation by 3 that would isolate
the x and the reason that would work is
if i multiply this by 3 over here i'm
multiplying by 3 and dividing by 3
that's equivalent you would just that's
equivalent to multiplying or dividing by
one these guys cancel out but remember
if you do it to the left hand side you
also have to do it to the right hand
side and actually i'll do both of these
equations at the same time because
they're really the exact same equation
so what are we going to get over here on
the left hand side 3 times anything
divided by three is going to be that
anything we're just going to have an x
left over on the left hand side and on
the right hand side what's 14 times 3 3
times 10 is 30 3 times 4 is 12 so it's
going to be 42 so we get x is equal to
42. and the same thing would happen here
3 times 1 3 is just 1. so you get 1x is
equal to 14 times 3 which is 42. now
let's just check our answer let's
substitute 42 into our original equation
so we have 42
in place for x in place for x
over 3
is equal to 14. so what's 42 divided by
three and we could do a little bit of i
guess we call it medium long division
it's not really long division three into
four three goes into four one time one
times three is three you subtract four
minus three is one
bring down the 2 3 goes into 12 4 times
so 3 goes into 14 3 goes into 42 14
times so this right over here simplifies
to
14 and it all checks out so we're done